l'administration pénitentiaire c'est une
administration qui ne recrutent plus
parce qu'elle paye mal ses
fonctionnaires l'administration
pénitentiaire c'est une administration
qui tue parce que vous savez
pertinemment que si vous les coursives
et comme nous sommes en mission de
sécurité à l'extérieur nous sommes
attaqués
encore récemment à angers et à toulouse
donc il est temps que ça s'arrête
il est temps que le gouvernement macron
et madame belloubet prennent les
dispositions qu'il faut afin de rendre
la dignité au personnel pénitentiaire
nous réclamons madame belloubet la
catégorie b comme toutes les forces de
sécurité publique
nous ne sommes pas des moins que rien la
prison nous avions une mission de
sécurité publique
aujourd'hui la balle est dans son camp
il y à une mobilisation nationale qui
est relié en outre mer comme en
métropole
c'est la raison pour laquelle cas du
causse aujourd'hui nous sommes mobilisés
afin de faire entendre à madame
belloubet notre voix